a newly released 9-1-1 call gives a look
inside the moments before a convicted
murderer was recaptured by police thanks
for joining us at 11 I'm Denise Valdez
and I'm Brian Loftus porferrillo Duarte
Herrera escaped from the southern desert
Correctional Facility last Friday taken
into custody five days later right
before he was set to board his shuttle
to Tawana Sasha loft is joining us live
from the bus stop Sasha this is where he
was caught with her top story
Denise and Brian that call was made here
at Las Vegas shuttles when Duarte
Herrera was about to board one of those
buses to Mexico the manager here sang
his staff recognized him from a photo
police had left behind
911 emergency if you need police fire or
medical a newly released 9-1-1 call
details the moments before an escaped
inmate was recaptured by police she just
called me and told me hey she told me
I'm not sure if I am tripping or
confused but this guy that checked in
with the name of Eric Martinez it's kind
of similar to the guy in the picture the
general manager of Las Vegas shuttles
unsure but suspicious as he describes
the man he believes is convicted
murderer Porfirio Duarte Herrera after
an employee spotted him buying a ticket
to Tijuana five days after he got out
okay so I just want you to give me a
description of the person that's on
property okay don't compare to what's on
the news just tell me what you see out
there at the instruction of the
dispatcher he shares what Duarte Herrera
who he says bought a ticket under the
name Eric Martinez is wearing all as he
set to board and they're getting ready
to load these passengers in yeah the
driver is just right now like checking
his two kids as we now know officers
arrived in time and took the inmate into
custody the call ending with the
dispatcher thanking the manager for his
quick thinking all right thank you so
much I appreciate it thank you
now I did check the Nevada Department of
Corrections website for Duarte herrera's
records it does list him in the system
currently but did not does not say where
he is currently being held since his
recapture reporting live tonight Sasha
Loftus 8 News Now